hey jared how you doing
morgan hoffman
hello uh before we get into the series
and you're so good knit um i wanted to
ask you
you know working in an office
environment is not everyone's forte i
wanted to know have you ever worked in
an office and were you any good at it
it's a great question i haven't had that
one before um
i i i i have worked in an office of
sorts and like a you know in a
production sense but i always had the
i always had
you know large periods of time where i
was traveling or gone and and of course
when you're an artist you don't really
work nine to five so the studio is
probably the most office
i've ever like environment i've ever
been in and you know it's more of a
creative enterprise so you kind of make
your own hours and your own roles
that's true so you're saying you would
not be good in an office environment
like a tradition i i don't think i would
be good i i was more of a you know i'm
i'm not so good with contained spaces
like that
me neither me neither um you know you
are so well known for completely
immersing yourself in every single
character that you portray what was it
like becoming adam newman for months on
end especially in this series where we
see this character go through extreme
highs and lows
it was incredible i mean for me it was a
gift i i really uh i relished the
opportunity here and i was i had about
six months total of of being immersed in
this character it was incredibly the
guys incredibly verbose of their
speeches on speeches on speeches and
tons of dialogue and you know i would
end every day just shattered but i loved
it i loved every single second of it and
i learned a lot
you know it was an opportunity for me to
kind of dive deep with a new character
who was really colorful
and kind of examine this story and these
circumstances which were just
extraordinary
did you have fun when you were playing
him at kind of the height of the success
of wework because you look like you were
having a blast but that's a lot of
energy
yeah i mean you know working in the way
that i do is
the thing that people don't talk about
is how much fun it is as well it's it's
really exciting it is really fun to work
that way it's risky and i think taking
great risk is exciting and that's
that's enjoyable so you know there was
lots of improvisation lots of ad living
i mean
it was just i tried every day to
to fail and uh and in that failure and
i'm serious i really tried to fail i
wanted to make sure that i was risking
greatly enough that i had the the
opportunity and uh to fail at any any
moment and i thought that was a really
good place to be in
yeah that's cool um you know obviously
you have special effects makeup and
prosthetics how important is the
physical transformation when you're
playing a character like this
i mean it's important but it's
meaningless unless you have an inner
life unless you have the the heart and
the soul and the spirit all of it's
for naught it uh
and that's the arguably that's the most
important thing is the inside
yeah and you nailed the accent how long
did you work on that before you felt
like you had perfected it
well i came straight from italy where i
was doing italian uh hausa gucci and i
was went straight to new york and i
surrounded myself with this great team
of israelis who helped
teach me guide me and uh
we just dug in deep and you know when
you i always feel like i have an
obligation if you play a real person
that to
to do the diligence to do the work and
to do your best at bringing
um
an accurate representation of this
person to the screen yeah it was really
fascinating for me not only learning
about the highs and lows of wework and
kind of what happened but at the center
of the story is a love story why was it
important to really showcase and
highlight the love between adam and
rebecca
i think in this case
you know there's a bit of a
it's said a lot about who they were and
that relationship was really important
both at the workplace both in their
personal lives
and that dichotomy of having you know
uh
being that colorful character like adam
was but also being this incredibly
committed loyal husband with five or six
kids and
um i thought that was really fascinating
and she was a really an integral part of
the story
yeah um you and anne hathaway have such
great chemistry i loved all of your
scenes together it was pretty cool to
realize that she was the one who
handed you the oscar in 2014 did it feel
a little full circle getting to work
with her finally on screen after all
these years well you know i we never
spoke about it and we we still haven't
um but
i was excited to work with her because i
i
just think she's
an absolute
legend i mean she's a pro she's such a
good actor
she's got such an incredible uh amount
of talent and
i knew that she would be the perfect
partner in crime here i mean she really
i think we both thought we have an
opportunity with the characters and the
material to see what we were made of to
test ourselves to grow to challenge
ourselves so we were on the same page
and you know she knew that i wasn't
going to let her down on my watch and i
felt the same for her and it was just a
really great collaboration
yeah she said she had a lot of fun with
you um and getting to work so closely
and there's also a moment where you guys
went viral at the vanity fair party
where you photobombed her with your
oscar people could not get enough of
that image do you remember that night
and how excited you were
yeah i remember it was a pretty wild
time a pretty fun time uh
and
yeah i mean i i i
you know those moments are are beautiful
but
you know i have to say like life is made
up of many more small moments um
and uh
you know it's important to recognize
those as well and this this every day on
this set i i was just struck with so
much gratitude to be able to
it
it was i was i was grateful for the
exhaustion i was grateful for
um
the exasperation that you felt when oh
my god i have this 10 page speech
tomorrow how am i going to get this pull
this off i loved that opportunity and i
really learned so much on this
that i'll take with me for the rest of
my career yeah i loved that katy perry's
roar was adam's pump up song in this
series
do you have a pump up song
oh yeah i mean i first of all i write
pump up songs uh for a living with 30
seconds to mars uh so you know a lot of
my songs are aspirational they're not
they're i don't really have songs about
uh girls or
you know boys and girls and dads and
moms and you know uh that kind of stuff
i i really my the constant theme in my
songs is about
they're aspirational um so so you know
uh yeah i've i've got i've got a few for
sure
that's awesome well listen it was so
nice getting to talk to you
cannot wait for morbius like i need to
see it right now and the trailer just
looks so good and congratulations on
this series you nailed it thank you i
hope to see you in person soon i know i
know one day
yeah one day